[Music]
jack yes is that time again
yes it is are you ready can you handle
the truth can you no i can never handle
the truth
that is why i lie to myself all the time
my life is a web of lies and i like it
like that
i occasionally get questions about the
naming of things in my field
all right and
let's take for example the names of
the moon
the planets and their moons
all right and had you ever wondered how
we get these names
not really but i i mean
i figured somebody looked up and said
i'm gonna call it that
because somebody did it right because
for me it had been like you know jupiter
and then jupiter a b c d
you know jupiter one jupiter two jupiter
you know that's because you have no
imagination right there well
that goes so
so here we go so the planets
are named
they all have roman
latin names basically okay and so the
name that they're sort of roman gods
mercury you know the messenger god
mercury is the fastest moving planet
venus is quite beautiful in the evening
sky um that object got named for venus
the goddess of love and beauty
um and then also in the sky of mars
which is red the color of blood
so the warrior god got named after
that planet or that planet got named
after the warrior god and let's keep
going you have jupiter
saturn
and those are the
those are the planets known to the
ancients and then later would be
discovered neptune uranus and neptune
right and
the thing about uranus was both it was
the first
it was the first time
anyone discovered a planet it was
william herschel
back in the in the 1700s and it was like
all the other planets were just known
because they're just in the sky
there's not the person who discovered
them anyone who looked up noticed them
so no one is on record for discovering
mercury venus mars jupiter or saturn
but uranus got discovered and it got
discovered by william herschel
and no one had discovered and therefore
no one had actually named a planet in
modern times well he took a good one he
tried to figure out what to name it and
so
so he did the right thing
okay he named it after his principal
funder
that's what scientists do
wow
artists do the same thing they draw in
the in the in the background the the
benefactor or whatever you know the
sponsor of the painting that makes the
the rich folks feel good right
so uh so he he named this new star after
king george
okay
all right
that's the king george that's of the
american revolution that same king
george because this is the late 1800
late 1700s and so that's the same george
that john hancock signed his big
signature
large enough for him to read and save
george
and hamilton
that's same george they're correct oh
that's same king george so who by the
way that king george god could he was a
show stealer
he was good
so i have books from that period so late
1700s early 1800s
where
the
the enumeration of planets is very clear
it's but we know earth is a planet right
so mercury venus earth
that since copernicus
we knew that earth is a planet as an
object that goes around the sun so we
have mercury venus earth mars jupiter
saturn
george and george george
of course
and george right i have books that list
the planets in that order with those
names and
this was you look back and say what the
but what what that
you know and so
so
god we should have left that
i'm telling you right now that would be
the best thing in the world one day
we are going to get to george
with our greatest of technology greatest
of technology we shall one day
set foot upon george
so
instead of uranus i'm sorry uranus we
could have went with george's ass
planet
planet george's ass
we're gonna say with a british accent
right
exactly indeed
planet jules's ass
i'm sorry i'm so terribly sorry
i say one day we shall get to george's
arsenal i say
soul cap oh boy one day we'll get there
so looking forward to being firmly
planted in george's axe
okay stop that's enough okay
oh no oh no oh no no no no okay okay so
it would take a little while but clearer
heads would prevail
and how do you tell
the discoverer of a planet that he has
to unname it after his king this is very
tentative you know diplomatic
moments here
and so
finally we landed on
oranos
which at from what i have read is
similarly pronounced in
uh in both greek and
and and latin in roman um uh it they're
they it's the same word all right so
it's actually a crossover name between
the the roman and the greek okay that's
cool
so that i'll show up later in a minute
so so and after that we get to neptune
that is a you know roman god of the seas
and this sort of thing and then when
pluto was discovered when everyone
believed it was a planet that um pluto
is the god of the underworld and it's
roman so there you have it all right so
you might say well what about the greeks
in the western traditions they were
pretty significant in what they
contributed to all of this it's not just
the romans right romans are like johnny
come lately compared to the greeks yeah
and so we said okay
in our western astronomical traditions
we will honor not only the romans with
planet names we will honor the greeks
with moon names
uh-huh
okay
there we go so all moons
essentially there's some exceptions here
i can get through all moons in the solar
system are named after
greek
characters
in the life of the greek
counterpart
to the roman god after whom the planet
is named
gotcha are you with me on that i'm with
you on that so basically
you take the roman
right you find a god
and then you say okay how's that
translate into a greek god and now we
got a name for a moon no i mean no right
no no no no you got you got you got
almost all of it almost so you got the
roman god right asked what is the greek
god counterpart to that roman god
okay now you look at characters in the
life of the greek god ah gotcha and
those are the names of the moons right
because otherwise you would end up with
just two gods two gods every two
difference of the coin
right yeah but one would be a plan it
wouldn't be a moon that wouldn't be
right that wouldn't be right yeah you'd
be pissing off some powerful god
so let me give you a list of some of
these moons okay
mercury doesn't have any moons and
neither does venus okay and let's skip
over earth for a moment we'll get back
to earth so what's next
mars
mars has two moons
and they're they're pretty sorry moons
just they're like a dozen miles across
they're not even spherical oh they're
embarrassments they really are you're
people wondering whether they were just
captured astronauts i was going to say
that sounds like a rock that's yeah
that doesn't really sound like the moon
it sounds like a rock that got lost
a wayward rock a wayward rock somebody
lost day rocks
[Laughter]
so
so the martian moons are called phobos
and deimos
phobos and deimos yes phobos and demos
as i have read in the in the in the
greek traditions that's the name of the
each of the two horses
that drives the chariot of mars across
the sky i gotcha
phobos and deimos yes which by the way
demos is a really cool name
deimos yeah yeah yeah it totally is
wasted on a rock
it is
what cool level name is
you wasted it on a rock yeah it looks
like an idaho potato it's embarrassing
it's embarrassing but that's all it's
got so
in fact uh one of the uh mars rovers i
forgot which was in the path of a phobos
or demo a phobos eclipse
right and so
so it's got a picture of phobos passing
in front of the sun and it's just this
outline of idaho potato
deep within the full disc of the sun
it's embarrassing yeah that is it was
like it couldn't even cover the whole
sun because it's so little
and it's not even round
so anyway let's keep going so it comes
after mars we get to jupiter
so
uh jupiter its four
brightest moons were named they called
the galilean moons galileo first saw
them through his telescope and then
described them but this is uh let me
remember we have io
ganymede
callisto
and i forgot one
uh callisto ganymede io and
don't look at me
i hope you're not helping me
out
you're not waiting for me to jump in
you once you got past ganymede i was
just like oh shoot
how could i forget europa my gosh right
which was the star of the movie 2010. so
um uh io callisto ganymede and europa
those are the four biggest
moons
of jupiter's i lost count is probably
near somewhere around 100 moons or more
because every time we get closer to it
we see other tiny little rocks and what
distinguishes a moon from just like a
not moon you know if it's just if it's
orbiting and it's bigger than a dust
particle is it a moon can you be in moon
no matter how little you are this is a
debate and i'm not going to bring that
up here but i'm just going to say those
are the four big ones and those are the
ones that kind of really matter
when you see jupiter through a telescope
there they are okay and there's four of
them and they just they go around
jupiter and
galileo when he first saw them he said
oh there's stars
near jupiter and then he looked later on
and he says wait the stars have mooned
moved he called them the gout the the
the
the jupiter stars right and because why
would you think you're discovering a
moon this isn't
you're coming out of out of nowhere and
landing on this information and so he
was able to see that they moved around
they orbited
jupiter oh my gosh that meant that earth
was not the center of all motion look at
that yeah
this this was devastating to people who
wished it were otherwise and the jupiter
stars sounds like a really bad
basketball team
really it does
it's a bad any kind of team right yes
exactly bad soccer team right right
so now let me take you to uranus
right okay
there was a pact
so as not to piss off the brits who are
very powerful in the late the 1700s okay
all right they're one of the most
powerful forces the world had ever seen
particularly with their naval power okay
so
do you gonna piss off the brits and king
george
what are you gonna do so here's what
they did here's what they did we said
okay we will make an exception of the
greek rule
for the planet uranus
and we will name the moons of uranus
after fictional characters
in the plays of shakespeare
oh
okay i have never
heard this that's ever so this threw a
bone back to the brits
so that they could rest easily that
their king was stripped from the name of
the planet and it had and it became a
roman god
wait a minute a constellation prize
no oh
god
yeah that was good chuck that was good
i said that
i gotta hand it to you so
what are some names we have porsche
p-o-r-t-i-a remember porsche from your
shakespeare um
a lot of characters from a midsummer's
night dream because that's a very quite
a fantastical
storytelling going on there
among the moon names we have uh umbriel
okay titania
miranda miranda is the lead character in
the tempest like we have ariel oberon
all right so puck
[ __ ] desdemona or
all these moons have names drawn from
shakespeare
that is i'm that is really stunning
because i mean
i can't believe that that's just
something that everybody should know
because it's so
like almost it feels so random
well it's a little bit of history
it's fun history it's not science so
much as it is just
it's the intersection of science taking
place embedded in our culture yeah
yeah so tonight you go out to the outer
planets by the way pluto the first moon
was discovered around pluto it was named
sharon i think in the greek is karen uh
and karen is the ferry boat driver
who carries your soul across the river
sticks to hades makes sense pluto god of
the underworld
well yeah it's but it's hades that's the
so you go to the greek side of that so
make a long story short so this is the
the the origin stories of the names of
the moons and in the very later years
when there are many more moons
discovered and you run out of incidental
characters in the life of greek and
roman
gods but we had many because they led
complex and interesting social lives
right so there's a lot of characters you
could draw from but in modern times a
more inclusive sensibility has descended
upon us and so now there are there are
there are names of of
of gods and other um uh
other spiritual beings fictional beings
in from other cultures not just greek
and roman
when we fully flesh out all the names of
all the moons so that's that that's uh
that's that's solar system moons 101
chuck oh man that's i'm telling you that
was really cool uh however
from now on i'm sorry i i have to call
uranus
george's ass
there you go chuck we gotta call quits
there okay all right
another star talk explainer
just just
blowing chuck's mind that's what i live
for
good i'm always glad it happens
and the first mission to land
uranus that's it
we will name features of uranus george's
ass i'll strive to make that happen
all right
star talk explainers keep looking up
[Music]